[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUJAA DEEPAK: Schlumberger is
a leading technology provider
in the energy sector.
And it started on its Cloud
journey with the ambition
to be the leader in the
energy solutions industry.
In 2016, Schlumberger
partnered with Google
as the provider for
high-performance cloud
computing.
This has resulted in the
industry-leading DELFI
cognitive exploration and
production environment.
It is an open, secure, scalable,
and fully managed ecosystem
connecting people, data, and
leading software applications
across the entire oil and
gas exploration landscape.
NIGEL LESTER: The
DORA assessments
have allowed us to benchmark
against others in the energy
and digital industries.
We have now clearly seen
that focusing on the DORA
recommendations to
test automation,
continuous delivery,
and monitoring,
has moved a significant number
of our solutions and services
into the high-performance
DORA categories.
SUJAA DEEPAK: We
recognized early we needed
to invest in not just the
cloud and technology ecosystem
but in all its associated
practices, governance,
and the skills to enable our
people to deliver best in class
services to our customers.
NIGEL LESTER: Our goal is to
improve the software delivery
and operational performance
of our cloud-hosted products,
because we want to deliver
the best-in-class service
to our clients.
SUJAA DEEPAK: So
what attracted us
was its holistic,
evidence-based approach, where
it focuses us to
improve on the most
impactful technical, process,
and cultural capabilities.
The impact is measured
by the four DORA metrics,
covering throughput
and stability.
NIGEL LESTER: It also helped
us to understand the results
and determine the most
effective way in order to--
the most effective
steps to take next.
So this has been one of
the critical things, which
has been identifying what is
the most impactful improvement
to make next.
And the Google team
have been incredibly
responsive in
helping us with this.
It's been a very, very good
collaborative relationship.
We would like to thank all
the staff at Schlumberger
for their commitment
and dedication
to improving our
customers' experience
by the wholehearted adoption
of the DORA initiative.
And finally, thanks to
Google for this award.
[MUSIC PLAYING]